李卓总 很久没见 很高兴啊
今天能够在香港你能接受我的这个邀请
来做个访谈
这是一次非常重要的访谈
因为呢 一直以来呢
咱们经历了很多很多的故事
你和比亚迪之间
甚至包括和我个人
那么这是个难得的复盘
对于比亚迪而言啊
你不仅仅是一个重要的投资者
你更是我们的老朋友
而且呢 也是我们比亚迪的发展
资本市场
以及公司发展以来呢
重要的参与者和见证者
也是非常多重要节点的建议者
所以说呢 我们想呢
给您花点时间
我们来聊一聊在过去
整理整理思路
回顾下过去 也展望下未来
您还记不记得您第一次
什么时候听到比亚迪这三个名字
是什么样的场景
你知道了比亚迪
你当时知道的比亚迪
你的第一印象是啥
这个算是 如日中天的
但是这个中国
因为这个比亚迪刚刚在里面
对
所以说您够回顾这件事就对了
2000年
对
那么过了两年
那我们发现比亚迪
对
也太厉害了
死灾了 就死灾了
那是上完学之后
秋天样子
一聊了好几个小时
十几年了
所以第一次的比亚迪
真正比亚迪赛那个之后
这个是最主要的
那当然 我非常清楚
日子过得也很快
那是2002年7月份上的试
然后你应该是秋天左右
跟王总见了面
你就不久开始乱得
应该你是仓位比较重
比较重
跟今天比金额不是大
但是仓位很重
对
我印象是可能有十个点的仓位
我还是记忆很深刻的
您和一般的投资人不太一样
后来我陪王总和您也见过多次
每一次
像我这种财务背景的人
基本就插不进嘴
一个小时 甚至两个小时
你和王总都是在不断的去讨论
战略 产品 技术
其实可能
财务的数字
只是轻描淡写的去了解一下
主要是也是了解财务结构
而并不是过于均匀于冰冷的
财务数据这一点
也是一直让我很感慨
也学习到很多
真正的价值投资
应该是这样的一个过程
那么王总当时留给您是什么样的一个印象
对
很难
他的所有和你没有
除了这几股冰淇淋
也没有别的所有
全部的冰淇淋
所以这样一个冰淇淋
坚韧的所有人
这种任何人都在发现
一定要抓住他
一定要就是他了
对吧
是的 我也很感慨
王总在比亚迪眼中
或者在我李前的眼中
一定是神一样存在的
也是我这一辈子
能够给我个人创造人生价值的
这么一个贵人领路人
但是我也很感慨
其实那个时候王总才36岁
你也是36岁
你俩同年的
他两个月
都是36岁
刚才你提到了
其实商业的本质
说明了王总就看得
他已经看透了
比如关于分享
他一直以来对于
整个团队的基地和利益分配
他是非常非常的大度和公平
而且是有长期考量
因为我在他身边这个岗位
我一定是知道王总的
长期考量在哪里
对于上下游的各种利益关系
他非常清楚他的责任和担当
其次他又有韧劲
和又有这种工程师的
这种专严的能力
和打不垮的精神
所以这是比亚迪的内核
这也是比亚迪特质
而且越来越强化
都是这样
王总的性格就是永不满足
这个时候你可能
零二年七月份上市的时候
我们只是做日差这波白锤
而且是个小公司
但是是个很有特点的公司
而且王总是个有特点的企业家
但是零三年一开年
王总就给资本市场炸了一个大雷
王总要进去汽车产业
收购秦川汽车股价暴跌
我们比亚迪和资本市场的关系
当天就进入到了冰点
您当时已经是投资人了
您的第一反应是什么
著名的粉厂
当时其实中国很多公司都要进军汽车
最后都买下去了
海尔波岛
秦川他就是倒了
没错
那么到了05年
比亚迪的第一款车F3燃油车出来
应该讲是一炮大红了
用燃油车来支持着比亚迪的整个
电动车的持续的研发投入
但是说实在的
那个时候比亚迪还是多条腿走路
电池仍然在做
汽车在投入
零部件是代工产业
也开始起来
从资产负债表的角度
当时还是非常的
负担非常重
研发又是王总一直非常坚持的方向
在那个时间点到了07年
当时资产负债表如果我们还记得
我们还记得应该讲
已经到了一个封在悬崖边上的
当时的诺基亚我记得非常清楚
想给你代工业务
但是又怕你撑不住
在那个背景下
我们开始了比亚迪电子的分拆上市
对比亚电子分拆上市当时
也是您在支持着王总去
要把它分拆要去募资
比亚迪电子的分拆是个痛苦的过程
但是我们还好
就说这个我们也坚定呢
这个世界一定会馈赠那些正值钱努力的人
所以我们在07年底呢
我们赶上个末班车
最后一秒咱们上的车
2007年12月份
对募了67亿港币
这样子呢让2008年的
这个金融危机来临的时候呢
比亚迪依然平稳度过
而且呢还可以持续大力研发
所以08年呢
坦白说对比亚迪而言呢
我们没有感觉到什么叫做金融危机的寒冬
而且08年我们还发生了一个高官时刻的事
08年您介绍巴菲特入口比亚迪了
我想请问您啊
为什么要把巴菲特介绍给比亚迪
您当时是什么想的
以及为什么是08年
不是07年
也不是09年
对
因为这个就是编辑的状态
但是这些呢其实不绝对的吧
因为这些其实都是经常去做
到了可能其实这个位置呢
还可以
还不错
但是这些不是我们要真正的去
不是
我们要真正的去
因为这些是本身的价值
是有建议体的建议
我也知道那需要改善
对
我们当时受了一些励诈
但是当时本身是编辑的
所以它的代理性是整个性
所以这个时候呢
对主题者的代理性非常好
我经过我的基金呢
就是留下了一个历史的阴谋
这个过程的阴谋
和这个过程的编辑
当时我们的管理人员
在这个时候的家属
就是一个兴趣的
兴趣的生命
这个生命的节点
这个就是一个共同的事
对
这是一个共同的革命
这是一个特别奇妙的旅行
对我来讲
因为一开始说巴菲特投比亚迪的时候
当您把这个消息传到我们这来说
其实从我个人内心里面
觉得这怎么可能
这怎么可能
后来我在巴菲特的股东大会里面的发言里面
也对王总以及对我们几位团队
比亚迪也是高度保密的
只有三四个人知道
包括我在内
也是高度评价
在这一个多月内我们并没有去炒作
我们的股价非常的平稳
没有变化
这也是一定程度上
也体现了这个团队
是一个有职业操作的团队
咱们敲定那天
开完电话会议
晚上当天我熬了个通宵
我准备协议
我准备发布会
然后第二天早晨
我很早就答应了国内的一个券商
他们来三四十个投资人来比亚迪调研
我其实熬了整个通宵
但是我答应了他
我要接待
我第二天还是要去接待一下
王总还打电话给我
身体没问题吧
我说王总没问题
协议基本定稿
咱们就看当天股价不移动就好了
这个deal就完成
然后我认真地接待
我接待完了这半个小时
他们要去参观工厂
我就对他们说对不起
我的同事陪你去工厂
我还有一件重要的事情要处理
结果到了当天晚上
新闻出来是巴菲特入股比亚迪
其中的一位投资人还是谁
把他给了记者
记者写到新闻上说
他们在接待比亚迪董秘李前说
我还有一个重要的事情接待
原来这件事情是巴菲特入股比亚迪
我们八块钱
八块零四收的盘
八块钱的定价
当天礼拜一开盘十六
后来冲到了八十
所以这对我而言
是我人生的一个高光时刻之一
也是要感谢李路总
您创造了这个契机
这也是双赢
大家双向奔赴
那么Mongo其实也一直评价您
他最好的投资就是您
然后在整个资本市场圈
毫无疑问您是华人的投资巨匠
这已经是大家公认的
包括也是我心理上的
但是也是我心理上的
对您的一个崇拜或者高度认可
但实际上这件事情
我觉得更有意义的是什么
你架起了中国和西方的桥梁
正是因为这一次投资
中国跟西方资本市场
尤其是像巴菲特这种
Bookshare
如此伟大的投资公司
与中国企业之间的纽带的连接
甚至于我认为这个影响
远超过了这个挣钱本身
到今天比亚迪国际化
我们能够在海外
以两三年的时间
走完别人十年
甚至几十年的国际化的路
我个人认为也是与当时的入股
让比亚迪在全球声名雀起
也是有息息相关的
今天的我们走到全球资本市场
都知道哇 BYD
多种原因
我相信这也是重要的原因之一